Bud Light experienced another week of
sales decline dropping 24 from a year
ago this is a fox business story Bud
Light experience another week of decline
last week of May with a 23.9 decrease in
sales on a dollar basis compared to the
same period last year and sales have
fallen another 24 and a half percent the
past four weeks according to Nielsen IQ
Data the sales decline can be attributed
to the backlash faced by Bud Light and
parent company
Anheuser-Busch since creating custom
cans for its transgender influencer
Dylan Mulvaney in early April however
the week ending May 27 marked a smaller
decrease compared to the previous week
factors contributing to the smaller
decline include effective communication
by enhancer Bush Distributors continued
merchandise placement by retailers and
Strong Memorial Day sales driven by
discounts and rebates and challenging
comparisons to 2022 sales Tom
this is really funny I don't need to
talk about this anymore I mean this is
this is some Budweiser walking with a
permanent limp the way they've shot
themselves in the foot well but what is
happening on the back end for beer
drinkers at one good beer Pat check this
out well once a year you have the Great
American Beer Festival and that's in
Denver Colorado it's known as the Oscars
Brewing
um and it's uh run by you know
independent mines and Sam Adams has
always been a great uh supporter of it
as a matter of fact back in 2009 I
finished third place American pale ale
competition shout out to you I'm not
joking Biz Doc is a craft Brewer on the
side when he has space and time which is
hard with the stock babe and two girls
in school but what is happening right
now is the craft Brewers used to make
Rich tasty beers you go into a bar or
something like Minnie and it's oh you
know the Oregon honey beer it's got a
rich different taste what they've been
making over the course of the last two
years is more
um fast drinkable and mass drinkable
they've been aiming at Budweiser
ironically and there are these five
breweries that have come out of nowhere
and they're being covered on social
media by their followers there's things
going on so what is happening is the
American entrepreneur
uh and craft Brewers are fighting back
and you've got people like the Odell
Brewing Company in Colorado Creature
Comforts in Athens Georgia exhibit a
brewing company which I think is
hysterical and Framingham Massachusetts
dovetail Brewery They are all Brewing
better than Budweisers it's mainstream
American pilsners aim to be better than
Budweisers and they're taking off
because they've gotten lift over the
past month because people are saying why
drink Budweiser why don't you drink the
dovetail Brewery Budweiser copy but it's
actually better than Budweiser and so
American Beer Drinkers are supporting
small entrepreneurs craft Brewers that
are Brewing stuff up so it's not just
the boycott the consumer the Beer
Drinker didn't stop being a Beer Drinker
for the summer they're looking for
Alternatives and are finding it and
they're finding it coming from American
entrepreneurs coming out of the Great
American Beer Festival and I think this
is a fantastic unintended consequence
coming at budwe Tom who who just ranked
up to number one as the most popular
beer in the United States in terms of
mass produced mass-produced
mass-produced Factory beers Modelo let's
go baby
you're in the world model is number one
there's problems do you guys like Modelo
I only could drink it with like like a
michelada or something I only drink it
when I'm pissed off but I'll Pat you
guys see what Dylan Mulvaney said about
this whole thing he said uh more
companies should work with more diverse
groups of trans people after this whole
debacle would Bud Light and he said and
I quote for a long time I felt so lucky
that these opportunities were coming my
way that I thought it was by accident
but now I realize how much power I
actually have he goes if a brand wants
to work with me so bad then they should
work with other trans people too it's
not enough just to hire me this white
skinny trans girl I want all the dolls
to be getting brand new like all these
brand deals go ahead so if you're
listening you're a company start hiring
a bunch of these a bunch of these guys
and see what happens to your company it
better not be a masculine freaking but
like numbers numbers don't lie don't
face
don't favor them no it doesn't and it's
in beer it's not just a boycott we are
now shifting away from giant woke
Factory beer companies and independent
entrepreneurs and little Islands in this
company a country are winning and I
think is fantastic so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]